hi guys so don't order finally release
some more information about life is
strange to can't do as long as we're
together I loved the first game first of
all what was this new information well
what you need to know is that it's gonna
be released on the 27th of September on
Xbox one ps4 and PC and it follows the
story of two brothers quite like the
first one it is a coming-of-age tale
however it's based primarily around male
protagonists this time and they did
allude to there being some secret powers
they also said that those who played the
captain spirit DLC will see references
to that which I'm glad because I don't
want that to be the end of Chris's story
with his drunken dad but you can already
see the ties because the two boys that
this story is about can actually be seen
at the end of the dlc they're his
neighbors that the ones are just like
randomly wave the trailer shows a tale
of two boys who get into trouble with
the law and then have to go to bottom
puerto lopez whatever lobos what the
lobos I'm sorry in Mexico to find some
family and get some help so the story is
all about their journey about going down
there however at the beginning you see
this like weird montage of a police
officer with a gun to the oldest
and the hardest spinning around so I'm
thinking in the captain spirit DLC was
it really his superpowers or his
deceased mum that helped him out at the
end of the game or was it actually this
new protagonist with his new powers we
do have names for these characters as
well is Sean and Daniel Sean is 16 and
Daniel is 9 so they're both so pretty
young it's all going to be based around
how you are going to be a role model for
your younger brother also Johnathan
morali will be making a new soundtrack
which I'm really happy about because I
freaking loved assisting to all of the
soundtrack of the old life is strange
songs even just the moments of calm are
so nice to fall asleep to now we've got
the hard fats out the way let me tell
you why I loved life is strange that's
what I love about life is strange
because it's it I feel like it is like
bridging the gap between film and gaming
and why I actually kind of have some
slight concerns about life is strange
dude don't get me wrong I am excited but
I am slightly concerned as well
I'll go into it now let's start in my
mind life is strange really pushed the
boundaries of what a game could become
it used the episodic format that was
already introduced by games such as tell
tales Walking Dead but they're mixed up
with beautiful visual art styles really
powerful soundtracks that also we could
relate to in our own lives because they
would be on the radio and things like
that and most importantly relatable
topics and environments and this mix was
able to hit us right in the nostalgia I
felt it hard
and this kind of relatability is it's
what kind of worries me about the next
game because no I know not all of us
we're girls in school probably not with
abilities to refine time and literally
having to worry about maybe ending your
town to save your best friend my screen
has turned off hold on which yes I did
decide to do that because I thought that
no one else would do it and I just
wanted to see what the ending was and
now everyone hates me and I still get
comments on that video stop but the
majority of us have been in a school
environments and we've grown up we've
had to go through losing friendships and
forming new ones feeling hopeless
feeling lost being bullied feeling like
we don't fit in we have all felt that I
am certain of that and this game touched
on that yes in a very extreme sense but
we could relate in some shape or form
which may just then feel more
emotionally connected to the choices
that we made in those scenarios because
all of these emotions everything that
max went through you're forming
friendships deciding whether she wanted
to be with a boy helping your friends
through a really traumatic time in her
life is all part of growing up it's all
part of what they call finding yourself
and we all go through that time even if
we're way past that now and we buried it
deep down beneath ourselves because
there is a strange dark hard time it is
still there and life is strange was able
to resurface all of those feelings
it made us relive the moments of our
lives or we were most vulnerable but
also at the moments of our lives that
were most pivotal
in creating the person that we are today
and it makes total sense why we felt so
emotionally invested in the game when it
was reminding us of ourselves and bits
of ourselves that we might have even
forgotten I realized I really am
analyzing this like so much but this is
just who I am as a person okay so if you
didn't feel this way about this game do
let me know in the comments below but
I'm just gonna carry on my ramble now so
but overall I really feel like life is
strange was a massive milestone in the
gaming community it talked about taboo
subjects in a really respectful way and
a way that could be understood by those
who had not gone through such extreme
situations but also related by people
who possibly could have gone through
this situations or did go through these
situations and it made the topic less
taboo people were talking about it
people were discussing it people were
wondering how you could save someone in
scenarios that were shown throughout the
game which definitely needed just the
little percentages of how many people
make the same choices as you or the same
kind of mistakes as you makes you
realize that you're not alone in the
choices that you make and I think that's
massive as well and they manage to keep
this theme through all DLCs I feel
growing up and realizing that your
parents aren't perfect because that's
always a pivotal moment you have this
idea in your head that your parents are
perfect when you're a kid and they can't
do anything wrong and then suddenly as
you grow up you realize that they're
just human and they don't they don't
really know as much as you thought they
did and that's always a really hard time
to come to terms with and also they were
based in environments that we could
relate to they were based in homes in in
schools maybe not everyone goes to a
junkyard though I mean I haven't been to
a junkyard but I can relate to having a
safe place that probably is a little bit
dangerous that you feel kind of cool
going to you as a kid we could relate to
and we can remember while playing the
game
did that you know even playing the
awesome Adventures of Captain Spirit we
remember being a kid and drawing silly
figures and writing those stories we all
did that as a kid so we remember being
free and being innocent but also being
terrified sometimes of adults and
authority figures because you didn't
really have any control of that stage so
showing that situation of and slightly
aggressive slightly yeah aggressive
drunken father is of setting and also
relatable not because you might have had
that kind of father figure but because
you understood being a kid how
terrifying that would have been if
people above you were like that because
you were out of control and you were
vulnerable very vulnerable at that point
now let's go back to life is strange - I
mean it's based around Brotherhood so in
theory if you have a sibling you should
be able to relate to this in some shape
or form however it's the environment
that I think it's going to be so
different because like I said most
people have gone to school everyone's
grown up in a home I hope these are
things that are just second nature
they're just normal however I can't
really say that most of us have grabbed
our younger sibling and walked through
the woods trying to get to Mexico never
really done that can't relate sounds fun
also sounds kind of scary but then at
the same time they're trying something
new and I do look forward to seeing how
are they going to do it I mean don't nod
are amazing at just really pulling your
heartstrings really making you empathize
with the characters and also making you
form bonds and a close connection with
all of the characters that
flash out throughout their games so well
so I'm sure they'll be able to do that
I'm just not sure if we're gonna have
that same connection of relatability
through this new game because of the
environment and the narrative that
they've decided to tell it will be
interesting to see how your younger
brother Daniel develops due to your
actions and your choices throughout the
game as you'll be his main role model
it's still gonna be some really hard
decisions as you know in life estranged
there were so many hard decisions to
make there but anyway that was just the
news I wanted to share with you their
little update because I'm super excited
you guys know I love life strange I
stream and every time it's out and I'm
very excited and then I read about this
and I was like oh oh I have thoughts and
I want to share them and see what you
think about it cuz I know some people
weren't so into the DLCs I was I really
liked them but yeah I'm just thinking
this next one is so so different to what
they've done before so I am just hoping
that it's not too different and I can
still feel like it connects to me in
some way like it connects to my past
self because I haven't played a game
that does that
no I don't think that I've ever played a
game that has touched me in that way
it's getting weird and weird don't
forget to subscribe if you do want to
see that livestream and click the bevel
so you get notified it's it's a while
away though actually September it's like
a few weeks away that's not bad yeah let
me know what you think about life is
strange too if you're excited and if
you're excited to watch them play it on
the 27th of September which is its
release date so super excited have a
lovely day or evening
bye [ __ ] I feel so embarrassed but that
was so hard
[Music]
Oh some sad
okay sorry give me a second
I'm so embarrassed